uh yeah or yeah or yeah we're seven
minutes deep
excited man the playoffs gonna be crazy
i'm ready for this weekend
indiana and uh washington coming your
way tonight here on tnt
but we do want to take some time now and
let you know who the finalists are
for all of the regular season awards in
the nba and we will start
with the mvp so here are the three
finalists based on the voting
so your three top three potential mvps
in no particular order
there are steph curry joelle embiid
and nicola yokin wow jack what you think
well based on these
guys rules which i don't think it should
be that i'm going with steph curry
because
kenny has said he's the best player on
the planet i've been saying that all
year but according to the rules the best
record and all that
so my question to the panel is when
we're in the all-star game
and the guy gets the all-star mvp why
does he get the also mvp because that's
the best player
no because yeah yeah yeah yeah they've
never given
i think maybe one time they gave it to
me have you ever given it to a loser
hold on
because the team won however because of
that best player how he played the
individual play
finals mvp yeah the team won but the guy
that's dominating the finals
that's where the mvp is most yeah the
the winning fool yes
no no player what no no you just name
all the winners chuck just
chuck listen what i'm saying you just
said the winners they picked the best
player
on the winning team okay winning team
but they say the player is the most
valuable player yes
there's a lot of guys that you know
played good on the bad team but the guy
that played on the win team played
better and that's why they won
wait what are you saying what you mean
what i'm saying you just said we we said
that
the guy who's on the best team wins mvp
and you just said the sec i said i said
i said at the all-star game
yes when the guy wins yes the best
player gets the mvp
yes right okay okay why because he's the
best player because they won
team one why do you think you won
because he's the best player that's what
i'm saying
player four player but they kill you
exactly right i get what you're saying
uh i know you're gonna have to what's up
dan steph curry is the best player in
the league i don't care what his record
jeff curry's in the play-in game
don't matter steph curry's in the player
he's still the best player
he i mean if if if he's still the best
player in the league stop it
i think that's two guys i would i would
love to have seen
you know in the top three possibly
taking one of these spots i don't know
where how or what
that's cool that played the whole season
yeah because the cyber season he was
doing what he was doing and how he
put the confidence in the battery yeah
but he's not playing like stuff no no
i'm just saying
i would have liked to have seen him do
the whole thing he's not playing like
steph no no no no steph curry i said
he's the best player
however there is a chance shaq
that the guy might not make the playoffs
so i don't know if that
can constitute every mpp of the league
value to the teams they're current the
best players okay
okay okay but also you're having the
best season doesn't make you the best
you know having the best i know you've
been lobbying hard for chris paul you
disappointed he's not in the top three
or can you see that
well the way steph has played i think
that
he kind of edged out cp3 i would have
liked to see
i mean what he's done for phoenix uh i
would have loved to see
chris in there but it's no doubt in my
mind uh i do agree with uh
uh shaq the way steph curry's been
playing
now check they're not even in the
playoffs yet so he's not he don't
deserve
mvp joker's gonna get mvp and he
deserves it joelle got hurt by injuries
but i would love to see cp in the top
three but listen
nobody can take away from what steph is
doing right now okay rookie of the year
let's move on
uh ernie this is a tough one it is and
again
with a lot of the awards there were
there was so much time
missed by certain players and when
you're talking about all nba teams and
everything else and now for
rookie of the year is it lamelo ball is
it anthony edwards is it tyrese
halliburton those are your top
three again in no particular order
where's the kid from the knicks
uh emanuel quickly yeah did not make the
top three wow
but and and i don't know if i don't
think he can argue with the most good in
those three
quickly he's having a heck of a year he
is but and and they're winning
oh my god i reward
winning quickly has been he's been
fantastic uh no disappeared halliburton
has got
well he's stuck in hell over there but
so we might not ever see him
but i tell you what man are they winning
because of him are they winning
they went in partly because of him no
not parliamentarians
i would